[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci merci jérôme commandeur et
jérôme avant qu'on joue au mieux qu'à
douche je voudrais revoir une séquence
qu'on a fait d'arabie ensemble avec jean
luc lemoine avec valérie bénaïm sur
europe 1 et je voudrais vous montrer à
nos plus grands fous rires avec jérôme
commandeur est ce que tu te rappelles y
avait un mec qui nous raconter une
anecdote très très très longue
ah oui anodine là on est parti dans un
fou rire regardez ces partis regarder
des trucs mais à nous avec votre mobile
est on arrive dans le temps de dakar et
là il ya le pacha kenny lala qui me
demande d'aller chercher le courrier
donc je pars la capitale récupère le
courrier si l'on regarde tu te sois quel
fou rire moland ccc l'heure est venue ce
qu'on revoie à vendre mais est-ce que
vous rappeler de ce duplex qu'on a fait
l'an dernier avec laurent weil oui
c'était exceptionnel regard sans vous
inviter à la même dire regarde bonjour a
tous battus comment tu te rappelles ont
déconné non je voudrais pas déjà
présenté mes excuses parce que j'ai une
espèce de cabans dégueulasse
oui vous avez des questions ou c'est
juste pour me faire perdre mon temps
c'est magique tabac truc à te dire moi
oui
ah non moi non moi on sait si on m'a dit
que c'était toi qui avait un truc à me
dire alors dit
reims et on se fait chier à faire un
duplex à los angeles avec trois
personnes qui n'ont rien à se dire
mais pas une petite question si demain
[Applaudissements]
le monde secret des émotions avant la
bande annonce dans un instinct pour
l'instant on va parler de vous jérôme
commandeur oui c'est très simple c'est
demi kadouch le milk a douché géraldine
maillet vous allez vous mettre bien en
dessous du tube est à chaque fois que
vous répondrais mal strain questions sur
jérôme commandeur non non bien bien là
bien l'arroser j'enlèverai plein la
gueule genève rémy kadouch jérôme
commandeur enlèvera jamais kadouch lors
des oscars 2010 est jérôme commandeur a
provoqué un fou rire suite à une
anecdote pourri au loup d'une star un
lapsus de laurent weil ou un chapitre
c'est comme un chat [ __ ] n'a brad pitt
elles sont pas et qu ils répondent sur
l'écran non pas là aujourd'hui merci a
remercié la saison sèche à lady diana
anecdote pourri anecdotes pourri non on
va vérifier tout de suite on regarde ça
oui les grands tiroirs et l'afutt mode
satellite
elle est complètement con votre éditeur
en b2c ans je m'étais planté wendel
je ne veux pas que vous me parliez
regarder allez on va se ressaisir chef
du jazz qui devrait gagner l'oscar rien
quelle émission animée jérôme commandeur
entre 98 et 2000
rasta baignoire les mini comme kd2a ou
belle toute nue
alors qu'est ce qui l'animé buy-in y
aller une fois de réponse je suis
démocrate habits noirs rasta baignoire
d'iris
la technique bande ou musique s de la
musique ou de la daube balade ou qu'est
ce que c'est c'est quoi c'est nikos qui
partent pas ou c'est des varices ou la
cellulite à 15 ans sur la plage avec
dubaï et pour l'instant il ya deux
bonnes réponses sur 2010 ya un seuil à
cette pression il ya sept qui n'ont à
cette crise ça tombe c'est rien c'est
comme des petites dont la promo du film
barbecue jérôme commandeur est venu dans
tpm paix pour animer un jeu
quel est le nom de ce jeu questions pour
un barbecue qui veut gagner des merguez
tout le monde veut prendre sa chipeau
aux braises moi si tu peux
il me semble que j'étais left des
questions pour un barbecue à la très
bonne réponse lors de son discours
d'ouverture en 2017 pour la cérémonie
des césars jérôme commandeur annoncé
qu'une personne est absente pour
remettre un prix
quelle était la catégorie de ce césar la
meilleure musique originale le meilleur
montage
le meilleur costume ou le meilleur os au
boucau donc pas rousseau boucau j'hésite
entre costumes et montage à aller vite
vite vite
allez nous faudrait ton série 3 2 un jeu
montage non c'était trop tard c'était
trop tard et on regarde la verriez c'est
on regarde ça s'est fait à rien me césar
du meilleur montage devait être remis
par l'immense réalisateur chinois sierra
giran atterri à roissy à 18 heures mais
sa valise et à düsseldorf
donc là l'heure qu'il est doit être aux
réclamations china airlines entre engel
et en bermuda
d'où ma présence oui je te passe sans
succès mais moi mes fringues sont à
répondre y est d'accord on lui accorde
la ferme tant elle a fait cas là portant
alors enlevé on va me caler cadeau à
l'essai de damien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est dur à tant de choses iront aux
commandeurs infligées toute l'équipe des
pieds dans le plat on se faisant passer
pour une star de quelle star s'agit-il
matthieu delormeau patrick sébastien
karl lagerfeld aux jeunes des gosses de
fontenay il le faisait tout le temps la
radio sur europe 1 c'est karl lagerfeld
on vérifie dans cette chine garde
lagerfeld carne et on a on à olivier de
kersauson vous partiez avec lui en mer
simplement pas eu mal aimable cette
légende grecque est dégagée tout légué à
machad choupette lors de la 42e
cérémonie des césars jérôme a tourné la
fausse bande annonce d'un biopic d'une
star de la chanson
quel était le nom de ce chanteur de
légende rené la taupe joe dassin carlos
ou dalida
ben vu fidic c'est carlos carlos où le
physique de guy nasseys une attention
attention on joue tour 2000 cadeaux ok
ça sera à la dernière question
l'année dernière j'ai romeo mandat
bonjour à trois cadeaux parce qu'à
l'aller on joue pour toi
l'année dernière jérôme commandeur s'est
déguisé en femme pour un programme de
canal+ lequel le journal du hard le
grand journal
catherine viviane ou la new light avec
moi
non pas le journal du hard on pouvait
monter un ouais ouais j'y vais au
mondial 90 yann catherine habib ann
katrin îlienne catherine vidal je suis
venu pour une photo
[Applaudissements]
est ce que ça marche ça a battu vais le
tester sur moi juste pour moi allez
vas-y vas-y tu pourras pas trop hein
ça marche ça leur destinée géraldine
maillet imprenable pro soir là là là là
ça y est c'est à dire un baltringue pour
tes jeux là mais c'est vrai c'est une
horreur géraldine maillet n'a pas pris
une goutte d'eau sans déconner c'est
quoi vous avez un peu le pantalon
mouillé comme elle
vers 6h